[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between starbucks in india and the us
this is food wars
at a starbucks in india we get our hot
coffees in four sizes number one
a short
a tall
a grande
and the big boy
a venti
i can't think of a single reason you
would order a coffee of this size who is
putting this much caffeine
in their bodies me nikhil me
let's measure this to see if it has as
much as it should
whoa wait a second
starbucks i'm disappointed it's close
it's 18 ounces ish all right if i'm
paying this kind of money i want a bang
for my buck 20 ounces to the t i think
that's 20. i was about to dunk on
starbucks with actually give us the 20
they promised cheers
look into the eyes
of an insane caffeine addict
my vision has just gone blurry india's
iced coffee comes in three sizes
tall
um
and an even bigger one we got the trenta
i want to mention now that our venti ice
size is bigger than our venti hot size
the venti hot was 20 ounces this is 24
ounces
and of course let's measure it
can't believe you've done this
it's not even 16 ounces starbucks and
this has ice in it which should melt and
give you more liquid is that is that how
fluid dynamics works maybe not
but my disappointment is is palpable
yeah i'm gonna go 22 ounces uh it's two
ounces that's fine
it's totally not a big deal that's like
two sips i can't speak for anyone else
but already my bladder is about to burst
so maybe i don't need 24 more ounces in
my bloodstream if that wasn't exciting
enough
we of course have our biggest ice size
which is the trenta 30 fluid ounces the
bladder buster this is for anyone who
wants to spend most of their day in the
bathroom
so you think what 28 again 2 ounces off
you know starbucks four ounces more
won't kill you
it's actually pretty good
starbuck's actually good what the hell
anyone watches food wars knows we use
this measuring cup for everything and i
know i don't clean it
and i don't think joe's claiming that i
don't think julie's cleaning it so this
thing never been clean yeah
and of course if you're in the mood for
96
fluid ounces of starbucks coffee ba-bam
get yourself the coffee traveler aka
what joe drinks in an afternoon here in
india we don't have a huge coffee
traveler we just have
this little guy it's an india edition
tiny pet coffee traveler it's got a lot
of cool india iconography on it um
there's a batsman there is a an elephant
all sorts of cool indian stuff and you
can put in
355 ml of coffee in here which is around
11.83 ounces of coffee roughly a tall so
the perfect size we also have one liter
bottles for iced latte and cold brew
word on the street is they contain one
liter each or 33.8 fluid ounces it is so
weird using the u.s system of
measurement i'm so used to our normal
correct metric system but uh let's not
start an actual wall over here sorry joe
yeah
i don't care
let's take a look at calories a hot
venti latte in india is 289 calories for
comparison a normal serving of dal
chawal is 200 calories
in the u.s the same venti cafe latte is
250 calories so it looks like the u.s
has
13.5 percent less calories
it's at that temperature where it's like
room temperature
my brain my brain is swiss cheese and
everything i say is idiotic a hot venti
mocha which is also what my friends call
me is 473 calories and the us are venti
mocha is 450 calories so according to my
math once again that's a calorie
decrease of 4.9 percent what do you
think of that hot venti boy
okay joe it's not a competition
let's just try something a little
sweeter like this venti caramel
frappuccino which looks uh
decadent to say the least
oh my
god that is
so sweet
602 calories and i can feel every single
one of them in each sip okay genuinely i
have had spoonfuls of sugar that are
more savory than this drink
how can you make something sweeter than
sugar
how
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a lot of calories my man ours is
470 calories which is also 24 ounces now
i should note in the us the calories
listed on starbucks.com are quote based
on standard recipes and do not reflect
customizations
get this out of my face i hate this why
is this so and they put like they load
the syrup in here how can a human being
drink one of these i don't understand
and now our most calorific overall drink
that we have here in india a venti
strawberry and cream frappuccino
963 calories
oh my god i didn't even think it was
possible to experience a sugar rush
and a coffee caffeine high at the same
time at 963 calories this is nearly 50
percent of your daily caloric intake so
please drink this at your own risk and i
am a risk taker
i feel transported to
another dimension where everything is
more colorful and i can taste sound
i don't know i feel like we should have
an ambulance ready if i'm going to
finish this drink that's a lot of
calories i have to say i'm very
impressed our most highest calorific
drink is the mocha cookie crumble
frappuccino at the venti size and it's
only
590 calories oh god
this looks so bad
oh man it's it's like so powerful like
it's so sweet that everything from here
after the rest of my life is just gonna
taste like paper
so what about the cost this venti
frappuccino will cost you 390 rupees
which at the time of filming this video
is 5.14 us dollars
in the us a venti caramel frappuccino is
5.45
or about
413 indian rupees now i want to point
out that this is 24 ounces and not the
india 20 ounce venti so if we break it
down per fluid ounce it's about 11.5
cost per fluid ounce decrease in the us
let me give you some context about
starbucks in india they are catering to
the rich and the elite because it is
very expensive over here in south india
where i'm from you can get a filtered
coffee for less than 40 rupees which is
a fraction of a dollar and it's
delicious starbucks would cost you
upwards of five dollars and that's
unaffordable for most of india
here is everything that you can find in
a menu at an indian starbucks that you
won't get in the us quick clarification
some of the items we have here are
location specific and specific to the
season that we're ordering them it's
currently summer here in mumbai and some
of these items are store specific so
maybe you won't get them in hugo order
but let me know and here's everything
you can only find on the menu at a us
starbucks you can't get in india now a
bit of clarification we know starbucks
will customize drink orders and there
are thousands of variations in special
secret menu items ah thank you starbucks
so just to make things not completely
insane these are the official things on
the starbucks menu at both india and the
us cool and let's go all right let's
begin with all the hot exclusive drinks
starting with salted caramel latte
not bad stardust
mocha
boom we have clarified no sparkles
nothing about this cream stardust i
don't know what you're talking about
starbucks but
it tastes good
chai tea or as we call it here in india
chai
can i just say it's a bit of a pet pee
when you guys call chai chai tea it's
like calling tea tea tea let me describe
a good chai to you all right it should
be warm it should be gingery it should
feel like a hug from your mum in your
childhood and it should perk your
morning up and it should be under 10
rupees but this is expensive
[Music]
hello it's christelle and i'm here to
talk about chai which is actually my
favorite drink every person has their
own recipe for chai but it's a
combination of spices and black tea and
some milk and usually sweetened with a
bit of sugar but for me at home my
recipe cardamom is the most important
spice cinnamon ginger a pinch of cloves
and my secret spice is a bit of black
pepper just to give that lovely warming
spicy feeling but but it's not savory
it's just a lovely blend of spices
the flavor is not bad but i wouldn't
call this i wouldn't call this a chai
you know what this is a chai tea because
it's not quite a chai it's not quite a
tea
fair enough starbucks it's a chai tea
next up and the drink i'm most excited
to have tandai spice now tanda is
consumed primarily in north india in the
state of uttar pradesh where it's this
drink that's sweet it contains spices it
contains rose petals saffron and
sometimes optionally you can add bang
which is marijuana and it's completely
free legal and optional to add it and
people enjoy it during the festivals
like holi and mahashivaratri well i'm
sorry did he say that that that drink
has marijuana in it or you can't put
wheat in it i mean this is california so
if there's a drink you could put weed
and you think we would have it right
not bad it's got little pieces of pista
and badam and other nuts how did you get
tanda right and mess up something as
simple as a chai usa we got a lot of hot
exclusives i'm going to start all the
way down here with something called the
cafe misto
bland moving on almond honey flat wipe
flat white i like because it has like a
nice honey flavor to it but straight up
flat whites i just i don't get it
cinnamon dolce latte
i like it it's not too sweet a white hot
chocolate hot chocolate come on
this is like really good but i don't
know if i could drink a whole one of
those this is the caramel apple spice
no next steamed apple juice what apple
juice
add apple juice what are you getting
like
some apple juice right about now i
haven't seen it forever let's meet up
for apple juice cinnamon dolce cream
steamed milk
and barf vanilla cream when you walk
past that ice cream place in the mall it
tastes the way it smells like strong
vanilla i couldn't imagine have more
than two sips of that already my
stomach's starting to hurt i'm gonna be
so sick and now it's time for the cold
exclusives i'm not having a caffeine
crash at all
the citrus cold brew
citrusy out of everything this one has
kind of a nice mild flavor the cocoa
chai almond
i just had such a mild one i took a big
sip and this one is
sweet again vietnamese caramel cold brew
it should typically have condensed milk
but this has normal milk and it's quite
good nitro cold brew it's basically cold
brew but if you press a button you drink
it faster
it tastes like any other cold brew i'd
be interested to know what the nitrogen
process is what is what is nitro cold
brew well they add nitrogen to it and
you know what that does i have no idea
next up chocolate truffle cold brew you
know that sounds like something your
child self and your adult self would
want to combine if they had to
collaborate on a drink let's see if it's
actually
good absolutely not oh my god stardust
mocha again
hmm
i still don't know what the hell
stardust is there are chunks of
something
something otherworldly
it's it's like cookies and cream it's an
oreo it's an oreo tanda spice uh same
flavor but now cold
too much sugar for one young man to
consume i'm losing it
i'm seeing the light
oh no i'm literally seeing the light
there's a light above me you know the
funny thing is tanda is meant to be
consumed cold so this is the appropriate
temperature and way to drink it but it's
layered with so much whipped cream and
it's so sweet tonight requires a balance
of spices and sweetness and that's what
this is lacking and the final two drinks
are salted caramel and strawberry with
cream but i already tasted those maybe
maybe it got better with time you never
know you got to give everything a chance
[Music]
i'm never giving anything a chance ever
again and now for the pre-bottled drinks
they've got three of them in one liter
bottles this is the ice shaken hibiscus
lemonade looks quite refreshing
that is very nice it says it serves four
to five cups which if you're in an
indian family they're going to make this
last for at least 20 people and it's
very reminiscent of roofs which is a
rose flavoring that we add to water and
it's super delicious i think this is a
good substitute white mocha caramel cold
brew
oh my god i've gotten to the stage where
i can smell sugar i can see sugar i can
hear sugar i think i am sugar at this
point
starbucks signature chocolate normally i
would be very excited about this but i
am so soaked to the brim with sweet
stuff
it's actually good it's like the amount
of chocolate you want to put in your
cocoa but you know it's probably not
good for you
i'm losing my goddamn mind
all right starting down here something
you can only get in the u.s is the mocha
cookie crumble a frappuccino it's
looking a little
sad
so
food wars tip
bring your own whip
that's in all joe's tips
i'm not getting the cookie part of it it
just tastes like a chocolate milkshake i
don't know that's really doing much for
the flavor the caramel ribbon crunch
frappuccino
i don't know how anyone could drink a
whole one of these the recommended
serving for this joe should be like two
sips it's like sip number two
and i'm good for a week oh that high
fructose corn syrup is working overtime
in that one the cafe vanilla frappuccino
you know always keep this thing on me
the least objectionable one i guess
actually a little weak to be honest then
again after these two maybe it's
perfectly fine nitro
the official cold brew of the fast and
furious franchise joseph just pour this
on your engine and off you go off you
and vin diesel go it doesn't require ice
has a smoother flavor right now if you
want something a little bit sweeter than
your cold brew you can get yourself a
vanilla sweet cream nitro cold brew
joe [ __ ] with it we got our vanilla oat
milk we got a brown sugar oat milk and
we got a chocolate almond milk here they
are
not as strong of a flavor as i thought
it would be brown sugar
i'm definitely tasting it yeah not bad i
have reason to believe this was
unshocking i think i could shake it
without
i would recommend this one out of all
three but insist they shake it in front
of you you can get yourself an iced flat
white and an iced honey flat white
skip em iced cinnamon dolce latte and an
iced starbucks blonde latte
not bad
can confirm a sip is good i don't know
about a whole one of these already i'm
kind of like
starbuck teas or as my mom calls them i
can make this at home
starting off with indian spice majestic
wow okay
oh
can i just say drinking this after
everything else is such a breath of
fresh air you know it's a simple tea but
it's very flavorful very spicy would
recommend next up matcha espresso fusion
it's part of the trifecta of three
ingredients that have become very
popular in india matcha peri peri and
red velvet
[Music]
i feel like the espresso counters the
sweetness that it has and the matcha
flavors there again just cut down on the
sweetness and this would actually be
good now the exclusive hot teas you get
here in the us the royal english
breakfast tea latte london fog tea latte
honey citrus mint tea a jade citrus mint
brewed tea the mint majesty
mint matcha green all bad the trinity of
gross i don't want the peach tranquility
and they spelt tranquility but it should
be tranquility i feel like they missed a
trick though okay so those are the two
hot teas it's now time for the cold tea
starting with an iced green tea i feel
like when you start drinking green tea
it's a sign of adulthood and there's no
going back
that's actually pretty good and now i
feel old
hibiscus passion lemonade so many
ingredients but i know i'm gonna taste
only sugar hey
that's pretty good
it's kind of flowery fruity i really
like this a marvel espresso fusion oh
this is an iced matcha oh okay sorry
my bad my bad it's guys it's a starbucks
handwriting honestly sometimes i think
it's just doctors writing prescriptions
on these coffee mugs by the way let me
know in the comments what's the weirdest
way somebody has spelt your name in
starbucks
i prefer this to the weird hot sweet one
yeah i like the teas way more than the
coffee so
i don't know what that says about
starbucks but
i'm a fan i feel the exact opposite i do
not like tea at all and this is all the
stuff on a starbucks menu i have never
gotten and would like to never get but
gotta do it it's the job so we'll start
at down here at the starbucks in the u.s
you can get yourself iced black tea and
an ice black tea lemonade moving on you
can get peach teas we got an iced peach
green tea and an iced peach tea lemonade
so this tastes good because it's like
peach and lemonade i don't taste any tea
green iced green tea lemonade
oh grande not gr's the first giants
granny grande ice cream tea lot latte
lemonade i'm losing it see i don't i i
stop drinking caffeine for a second and
i fall apart oh matcha no
no not much huh grinding matcha lemonade
all right lemonade lemonade is doing all
the heavy lift on all these
i absolutely hate this royal english
breakfast
mmm
you know what help a little caffeine
all right also starbucks get something
called refreshers what i can tell they
are fruit juices with fruit in it
imagine that i would never normally get
a refreshers one thing to i'm not going
to try all of them pink drink
oh yeah fruity moving on we have the
strawberry acai lemonade
i like this similar problem to a lot of
the frappuccinos one taste and i'm like
i could get into it but a whole one of
these and i just feel my gut kind of
starting to look just the mango dragon
fruit right dragon drink mango dragon
fruit lemonade
i think this is the best one so far
one second all right
don't put that in
moving on we have the green drink zone
star drink assuming star fruit kiwi star
fruit does lemonade kick it up even
another notch
hmm this one i like the flavor the best
was a little strong yeah all these are
pretty good the last refresher is the
strawberry acai
they have a regular lemonade and a
blended strawberry lemonade i mean come
on lemonade everything else has had
lemonade in it i've enjoyed so let's
just go straight to the source
whoa dude starbucks lemon is like really
good
is this even the top 10 things you would
get at starbucks a lemonade what now
like your lemonade a little bit of
strawberry
this is fantastic wow even after all
these this is a standout this is really
good why is this so good
fantastic food
we have a lot of indian exclusives i'm
going to start with the salads this is a
vegetarian grain salad it's got quinoa
it's got some paneer in it it's got
corn kernels that look unborn
i'm sure this is super healthy but it's
also very dry now the meat version of it
it's got chicken
i'm not really a fan of cold salads if
you are a health freak you might enjoy
this but if you're a fan of food
you probably won't okay next up i'm
gonna try all of their rolls rolls are a
huge staple here in india they're one of
the most famous street foods and it's
great for the working class citizen this
is the murg kathy roll murg means
chicken in hindi
oh that's pretty good
finally some spice
oh my god
this is a lifesaver i feel like i'm
being brought back to life after all
those drinks this is really good you'll
find this only in india but honestly
starbucks you should consider selling
this all over because it is tasty
next up is a kakori kebab rule kakuri
kebab is basically minced
meat typically lamb and it's served with
a paratha or a roti i've never seen it
in a roll and i've never seen it in a
pink roll
[Music]
the main thing about a kafka kebab is it
should melt in your mouth this has too
much of a bite to it not a fan next up
chatpata paneer roll chatpata means full
of masala and flavor and it's zingy and
paneer is cottage cheese we love our
cottage cheese here in india and we call
it paneer and you should too
next up cheese chili toast so obviously
if you order this at starbucks i assume
they actually toast this and the cheese
melts and it's super delicious
i can tell you right now this flavor
profile will go really well with indians
we love our cheese chili toast monsoon
season mom goes to the kitchen toasts
the bread lot of butter some cheese some
chili bite into it your mouth's on fire
but it's rainy and cold so you're all
okay this is not quite there but i feel
like it could be next up tandoori paneer
sandwich i'm gonna have to say that this
bread is little
hard
to say the least
might be a bit of an old sandwich
flavor is good though if i had any of
this food fresh at a starbucks i might
have a very different opinion so far the
paneer items have been way better than
the meat items i'm starting to guess
that somebody in the starbucks r d team
who really likes paneer
sandwiches and protein boxes here we go
you can get a bunch of exclusive
sandwiches u.s starbucks starting right
here with the crispy grilled cheese on
sourdough again ham and cheese on a
baguette then we got the turkey pesto
with provolone and chipotle
chicken and bacon on brioche why is it
can we get that chicken of the whole
thing here guys a focaccia tomato
mozzarella at a starbucks you can get a
chicken caprese on chibata sandwich on
to the
protein boxes
the chickpea bites and avocado can you
tell what's in there obviously avocado
chickpea bites egg and cheddar
cheese and fruit peanut butter and jam
grilled chicken and hummus there's your
hummus there's your pita there's your
grilled chicken you can also get which
was not available at the store today egg
and gouda protein box a cheese trio
protein box in a cheddar and salami
protein box next up egg white and
chicken multi grain quasar should i just
call it a croissant to upset people the
denizens of the internet
if you are somebody trying to be protein
conscious put on the pounds this might
be good for you next up a masala chicken
quasar
i guess you can't go wrong with masala
chicken you can't go wrong with the
croissant it's just really good next up
a basil tomato mozzarella sandwich
i can imagine just eating this on a
summer day really yum next up creamy
spinach and corn pocket pocket that's
pretty cute as a kid this is the only
way i enjoyed eating spinach unless it
was in palak paneer but right now i
appreciate it and i really like it in
this
pocket next up chicken chic pocket she
kebab is basically minced meat and it's
sort of pressed onto your skewer and
then grilled over here they've done that
and then they've chopped them into
little sausage pieces
minty it has that podina flavor a lot of
onions that have just been caramelized
so it's like sweet or also spicy i
really like this starting with the
breakfast sandwiches and wraps the bacon
gouda egg scooter somewhere on here
sausage egg and cheddar the double
smoked bacon cheddar nick dude
ham swiss croissant
and bacon sausage egg wrap what's up
i didn't
[Applause]
other sandwiches you can get are spinach
feta egg wrap the roasted ham the turkey
bacon cheddar and egg white sandwich and
the impossible breakfast sandwich but
you know they do have bacon and greener
egg white and roasted red pepper kale
and mushroom
get yourself an avocado spread for
dipping
bagels we got em i'm gonna assume it's
in everything because it's got
everything cinnamon raisin i can tell
because of the raisins a plain for the
new yorker right oatmeal oatmeal
we got regular and they come with a nut
medley brown sugar dried fruit i bet
it's like a puck now it's been sitting
for a while
all right
you can also get a blueberry one
obviously same stuff with blueberries
strawberry and overnight grains next up
a double chocolate chip cookie
i think if i put this in the microwave
for five seconds this is a banging
banging cookie a tea cake this is a
lemon flavor and finally they have a
banana loaf cake but guys i am
dangerously allergic to banana and so i
wish this cake the best of luck maybe
you guys can try to let me know in the
comments whether it's worth ordering and
the baked goods in the u.s you get an
assortment of baked goods as you can see
in front of me i'll just start down here
we got scones oh this is a blueberry
scone petite vanilla bean scone these
can't be the same price
cake pops yeah chocolate which one you
think is earth or which one you think is
birthday
like this is guppy birthday glazed
doughnut hey
red velvet cake pumpkin loaf you can
also get a cinnamon coffee cake yeah
brownie chocolate chip cookie available
yet not today pumpkin cream cheese
muffin it is now time for ice creams did
you know starbucks makes ice creams i
had no idea java chip ice cream this
looks really good
check it out sun
yum
coffee chocolate chips and mocha that is
something else i really like this next
up vanilla ice cream and chocolate sauce
now everybody in india their childhood
has involved
amul vanilla ice cream and hershey's
chocolate syrup let's see if this sort
of evokes that nostalgia
oh the vanilla ice cream is so good next
up vanilla ice cream with strawberry
sauce you either got the hershey's
chocolate sauce or the hershey's
strawberry sauce
younger kinney would not have
appreciated this but ola kinni
really enjoying it it's fruity tangy
sour and it really complements the yummy
vanilla creamy ice cream next up we have
the same java chip but now with
more choco chips and chocolate sauce so
this is a bit of an overload
too much are you can you zoom in on my
hand
it's shaking right now caramel macchiato
hmm
it's really nice it's not too sweet it's
kind of salty next the affogato which is
uh ice cream in coffee
i love how we're taking hot bitter
coffee and sweet creamy ice cream mixing
them together and somehow they're not
choosing violence they're choosing to be
friends
harmonious in my mouth
i forgot to again but this is house
avogadro so i'm gonna assume starbucks
that this should be better you're
putting your name on it
tastes the same and finally we have the
caramel macchiato ice cream it's similar
to the small cup of caramel macchiato i
had except this does not have
a drizzle of caramel sauce
if you were ordering ice cream from
starbucks i would recommend the simple
java chip and the simple caramel
macchiato no drizzle of sauces it's not
as sweet it's kind of nice
ladies and gentlemen
we are finished with this video
thanks for watching be sure to like and
subscribe
i'm gonna go throw up